first weeks in office the Biden
Administration halted deportations for
100 days stopped all border wall
construction and suspended the remaining
Mexico policy critics say it all added
up to putting a come in we're open sign
on the door I don't think that the more
than million people last year that we
removed or expelled would consider the
Border open but the messaging was the
messaging wrong there that you know
we're open that wasn't our messaging but
that was the migrants were getting
because remember something that we are
not the only source of messages that the
migrants received Donald Trump said he
was going to build a wall and why was he
going to build a wall you either have a
country or you don't you a country is a
nation-state that has a delineated
border from another country so we are
not Mexico there is a There's an actual
border it's an agreed upon border by
both countries right and if you cross
that border illegally you have now
broken the law and we are allowed to
kick you out